um
obviously i'm using some of the quotes
that you said the last time that we that
we all spoke on patrick's
uh podcast and you said uh if i may
paraphrase you said
uh you weren't shy about it either you
said the following
saving is for losers uh that's funny to
me because my whole catchphrase is
save that money which we can get into so
when you hear stats like this robert
75 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck
seventy percent have less than a
thousand in savings fifty percent
uh don't have five hundred dollars for
an emergency
twenty five percent have no savings a
lot of that yes
does have to do with lack of financial
education in school
so my question is what's your advice to
those people struggling americans maybe
they were laid off
the pandemic obviously didn't help
things exacerbated things
what's your advice to those people on
saving who are not exactly in a position
to go
to the bank and take out a you know 100
million dollar loan
zimbabwe dollars so once you save those
you can use them as toilet paper
[Laughter]
you know you know and i i'm i'm i'm
being a wise ass
because i'm a u.s marine i speak that
language so we're okay don't worry
i speak wise ass you know and most
millennials in our snowflakes
you know i mean they can't they can't
you can't know the truth as nicholson
said in a few good men
but they can't handle it if you wanted
to know the truth you'd be listening to
valuetainment
that's why they come to you guys or or
if dave ramsey was here i'd agree 100
with him if you don't have any financial
education live debt-free
but i wouldn't save dollars i would save
silver
you know because silver is about to move
again
but i think this is what i i thought
when i found out about bitcoin
was that if it's valuable you hang on to
it
and because in 71 when the nixon took
the dollar off the gold standard
there's something intuitive you know
humans human beings when it comes
to money are pretty smart and they know
that cash is trash
so they spend it as fast as they can
that's why there's no savings
that's my opinion i can't prove that
gotcha but i
i'm never gonna say i'm not i'm never
going to spend my silver i'm never going
to spend my gold
i'm never going to spit uh save my spend
my bitcoin
i'm going to put it into a child of
ranger trust all my real estate and pass
it on for perpetuity
because it's valuable that's why
gamestop had no value
but silver did and that's why the robin
hood guys and
reddit guys couldn't couldn't move the
silver market
they tried to manipulate it but they
couldn't now because the biggest players
in the world need software
you know it was it was the guys uh you
know the guys in the comp comex and all
that stuff were manipulating the price
they're not the end user the end user is
apple
tesla water purification companies
electronic companies
you don't mess with superman and so the
price of silver is suppressed
intentionally so that's why you know i
stopped buying at 30. so
it's about 30 today becomes a time when
you stop
i take a position i probably have
millions in silver in storage outside
this country
real silver no etfs no paper
and when i when i get time to go to the
great rodeo in the sky
i'll just pass it on thank you for
watching this short clip if you want to
see the full
episode check it out right here and if
you have not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here